the sicilian has been around for over
400 years
and it used to be considered not the
best move because it's not symmetrical
e5 was of course the main line
but the sicilian really caught on in the
first half of the 20th century
uh when players started to realize that
e5 is not the only good move anyways
knight c3 e6 so i'm trying to control
the center with d5 that's not the only
move
you can also develop the knight you can
go d6
you can play a bunch of different moves
here and brad goes f4 which is a
perfectly good way of playing the
sicilian
[Music]
okay what's wrong with queen h4 so the
move queen h4 check
right it seems to deliver what's called
a fork and a fork
in chest is when you attack two pieces
at the same time
so here you attack the king you give a
check and the queen also attacks the
pawn
but forks can be defended against and
here white can play the move g3
which defends both the queen and the
pawn at the same time
defends both the queen and the pawn at
the same time and so the queen has to
return that's why
it's often times not very advisable to
develop the queen
before you've developed other pieces so
d5 check
knight c6 knight f3
so we're all developing our pieces well
the plot on c5 controls the d4 square
which is a central square
but isn't inducing the weakness on the
king's side good
uh it is but this isn't a very serious
weakness and
you've wasted a lot of time doing it so
when you waste so much time your
opponent is able to develop you can
fianchetto the bishop now
it's just it's too slow right you've
wasted too many too much time and this
is not significant enough of a weakness
what is the benefit of having the pawn
on c5 well as i explained it's basically
where
the bottom line is that this pawn
controls part of the center it sits
on the fringes of the center and just
like this pawn controls these central
squares
well this pawn controls a central square
and another important square on the
queen side
i'm oversimplifying it it's just one of
the normal first moves because it also
contests
the center so i could have also blocked
the check with the bishop
but then he takes my bishop and
what i didn't like about this is that i
have to take with a queen which is a
little bit awkward
because if i take with the knight what's
wrong with this who can tell me
what's wrong with taking the bishop of
the knight
using a method that i maybe one of kid's
viewers wants to take a stab at this
yeah he takes d5 and and white wins the
pawn and winning up on is good
and the way you determine this is by
counting the number of attackers and
defenders
one two one it's one defender
two attackers therefore the pawn is free
and so therefore i decided not to do
that and play knight c6
uh brad develops his knight so right
here we're just
bringing our pieces out of their initial
squares brad goes e5
chasing my knight to a slightly worse
square that's a good move
i have to move my knight because knight
is more valuable than a pawn
and if you guys have any questions time
your questions
with the moment that we are at okay
that's why i slowly go through the game
to avoid the pin could you play a6 well
that wouldn't develop a piece
why do you allow e5 doesn't this cramp
your space yes it does
but um space isn't everything so i have
enough space here to develop my pieces
so this isn't the end of the world
uh if that makes sense
uh he did play e5 that's exactly what
brad did uh a fergus what if he went 95
instead his bishop takes c6 any good
so okay let's take these questions one
by one thank you mrn top
um first question by danny cal
one why is knight h5 good so remember
when i said that pieces
can often be thought of uh according to
the number of squares that they control
so the more squares of these controls
generally the better it's going to be
well there's a chest expression knights
on the rim are grim or knights on the
rim are dim
and the reason that is is because
mathematically speaking this knight can
only
physically go to four squares the knight
in the center can go to eight squares
so this knight is just bad because it's
not controlling enough squares and also
it can be trapped
if white brings this pawn out to g4 so
knights on the rim
they don't have the real estate on the
left side of the board so they can be
liable to getting trapped
uh if knight e4 then he can take my
knight and when i take his
knight he brings his knight to g5 and
this pawn on e4
sticks out like a sore thumb it's way
ahead of its neighbors and so it's
basically trapped in enemy territory
it's like you're playing capture the
flag
and you run for the flag uh but then you
don't have time to run back you're
surrounded by enemy forces if that makes
sense capture the flag is actually
which i love by the way i think you
should be playing i think adults should
play capture the flag more
um but it's a good way to think about
certain uh properties on the chessboard
i'll be using that
uh in the future because i i hope most
of you guys have played capture the flag
okay um so another great question
uh when you retreat the knight to d7
don't you lock in the light squared
bishop yes
but uh piece placement is temporary okay
so when you put a piece on a certain
square right
uh that's usually temporary what i'm
basically saying is okay
i'm later going to move this knight out
of d7
and i'm gonna open up a square for the
bishop or i'm going to fianchetto the
bishop to be
to b7 peace development isn't like a law
you don't have to develop
all of your pieces in a certain number
of moves it is okay to leave a piece on
its initial square
if you develop other pieces and if you
know that one day you'll be able to
develop it
okay the other thing to notice here is
that the position is closed up
what happens when the position is closed
think of it as a war
and a closed position is like a
ceasefire in that war
when the position is closed the kings
are safer because they are harder to
access
because the center is one of the main
ways to access a king
through the center well the center is
closed the position is closed
uh it takes longer to build up an attack
and so it's less important
to have your pieces in full ready
defensive position you can take
longer developing your pieces does that
kind of make sense that's the philosophy
behind it
and when he plays e5 he closes down the
center
if you're a beginner then focus on
developing your pieces yes do not try to
violate the rules
if you're a beginner you want to try to
master the rule so don't be like well
daniel didn't develop his bishop so i
shouldn't either
try to focus on on healthy development
yeah i am cramped but but it's but
that's okay that's not the end of the
world so brad controls the center
um you guys you're you're e5 is not that
big of a deal being cramped is not that
big of a deal
and it's also a stylistic thing some
people are good in cramped positions i
think i'm one of those players
okay i'm not that great in any position
also don't get any illusions i'm not
nearly
there people are much better than me but
i like to play in cramped positions i'm
i think i'm kind of good at at finding
ways to get out of them
so it's a stylistic preference more than
it's like really really bad to be in a
cramped position
okay uh so knight takes d4 bishop takes
d7
so we we have a bunch of trades and i
actually brad i didn't like your move
bishop takes d7 because i feel like you
are giving up a really active bishop
for a a pretty crappy night i think you
should probably take
queen takes d4 and then perhaps the
bishop could
drop its itself back to d3 and aim at
the king side
so i think that maybe white is slightly
better here but there's nothing major
now if black wanted to trade queens here
how could i try to trade queens
how could i try to trade queens so i
don't show the computer evaluation
because i like to talk through the game
myself
and i like to go through the process of
trying to figure stuff out and getting
to the bottom of the position yeah queen
b6 is right
and uh this offers a trade of queens
which would lessen the load on my
position and after queen takes b6 knight
takes b6 finally i'm ready to develop
the bishop you see
so it wasn't such a big deal that the
development of the bishop is blocked
okay
so he takes my knight he solves the
problem for me
and now we go rook to c8 bringing the
yeah white can bring the queen back but
that would be a small concession
yeah so so in this position we have two
pieces that are hanging
um so let me think let me let me compare
this to the following
let's let's say you're playing a
knockout it's a basketball game right
you're playing a game of knockout and
you use your basketball
to hit your opponent's basketball all
the way to the other end of the court so
he has to run and get it
um so think of it this way when two
pieces are hanging
a white bishop and a black knight you
are already going to lose your knight
you're already going to miss the shot so
you might as well knock your opponent's
basketball to the other end of the court
by which i mean you might as well give
this night up for something you're
already losing the night
so why not give the knight up for a pawn
because you're going to take your
opponent's bishop anyway
so knight takes c2 is a very logical
move
the problem and if queen takes c2 then
we take white's bishop and we are up a
pawn
the problem is that white does not have
to take on c2
white can hit a full court shot why can
play bishop takes bishop
and if you're like no problem i take his
bishop then white takes the knight and
white is up a piece
the line doesn't end there but that's
enough for now
we can take white's rook white takes on
b7
we attack the bishop the bishop moves
away and if you count the material
you will find that black is up a rook
for a piece and a pawn
so technically right now black is a head
in material but
what is the extenuating factor here
think hey omid
what is the extenuating factor here
why didn't i go for this because the
knight on a1 is that guy and capture the
flag that's right in the end of the
enemy territory look at that knight that
knight's gonna get trapped
maybe a computer could pull this knight
out but i thought the knight was going
to get trapped
it doesn't have this square it doesn't
have this square white's going to move
the bishop out and he's going to win the
knight
so this line is the reason why i didn't
go for knight takes c2 i decided to take
his bishop instead
and brought the rook into the game brad
goes f5 starting the attack on my king
trying to open the position up
trying to open the position up um
now this is a a complex move here we get
into an area of the game where
the situation is super complicated so
those of you who are new to chess
you might have a hard time following
some of the details try to focus on the
bigger picture here
uh if you're a beginner try to focus on
the reasons behind the moves rather than
the sort of details of the variations
which i will show
so first of all um what what's wrong
with this mover what seems to be wrong
with this move is that it gives up the
pawn on a7
and the first thing i should mention is
that not all pawns
are you know are are of the same value
some pods are more important
than others in certain positions
particularly the pawns in the center
tend to be controlling a lot of squares
and holding your position together pawn
on a7 isn't that important
at the moment that doesn't mean you
should just give it up thank you
ch adams two one one two
uh and the second reason that it's worth
sacrificing
this pawn is because the queen on a7
is now very vulnerable to attack and i
can use this queen
as a tool to improve the situation of my
two bishops look at these bishops do you
like the way they're placed
because i don't they're kind of passive
they're like cramped together
why don't we put one bishop on c5
he has to take our pawn and the other
bishop on c6 now look how much better
these bishops
are and if the queen drops back to b3
take a good hard look at the screen
thank you brother dan for the prime
it can't go back and it has no other
squares
so what move does black now have
we can go rook to b8 attacking the queen
and trapping the queen the queen has no
squares it is trapped white loses the
queen
all right loses the queen and the reason
why it has to take the pawn here is that
the queen has no
other squares on the chessboard to move
to other than to take the pawn
so the queen in this position has to go
to a6
but now you see this bishop on c6 do you
guys see that it's staring at this pawn
that's not a good situation you don't
want a piece of yours to bite on top of
a pawn you want it to be open so what
can you do
you can push that pawn out now the other
bishop is staring at the pawn but at
least this bishop is staring at white's
king
and now you can do what's called
building a battery you can put one piece
on top of another piece
so a queen on top of a bishop or a queen
on top of a rook
and when you build a battery you
threaten checkmate on g2
now let's say that white defends the
checkmate
by playing rook to f3 or sorry let's say
y plays
rook to g1 now we look at the other
bishop and we say
i don't like the way this bishop is
placed now this bishop
is the one that's not joining joining in
the party that's not fair so get out of
here pawn
and guess what we win the rook and not
only do we win the rook but we deliver
checkmate on g2 because white has
nowhere to stop it so
that is a little window into how good it
might be to sacrifice pawns pawns aren't
everything
so when you have an aggressive style
you're more prone to sacrificing pawns
for an attack
which is not always a good thing
sometimes you can sacrifice a pawn or a
piece and it can backfire
the attack might fail and then you end
up down whatever you sacrifice then you
have no
nothing to show for it but uh this is a
little window into how complicated this
position could be and that is why i
sacrificed the pawn of the corner i
don't know if that makes sense
so he goes f5 now we bring the bishop
out to c5 this is a move that you guys
should be familiar with we make our
bishop better
he drops his queen back if we take his
pawn this pawn on f5
was a very nasty pun it wanted to go all
the way to f6
and destroy the defense around our king
okay um why not b6 because the rook is
much better on c8 than it is on a8
on a the rook was like very passive
we're just staring at the pawn
on c8 the rook is at least controlling
more squares always think about it in
terms of square control
how many squares is a piece controlling
what is a piece doing
if a piece isn't doing anything you can
think about making it better
okay so he takes f5 he takes our pawn
now we look at this bishop this bishop
is not doing much let's reposition it to
a better square we also open up our
queen
c4 b5 undermining his pawn so now if he
takes his
our pawn then we take his knight uh the
reason i played bishop e6 and not bishop
c6 reactionist is because this move
although it was probably also good but
it would have left this f5 pawn without
a defender
and it is true that white cannot take
the pawn immediately
right white can't take the spawn because
he drops his knight but after c4
this pawn is hanging and i didn't want
to give up this pawn
so this is a pawn i don't want to give
up i don't sacrifice every single pawn
on the board
okay so uh he defends his knight we
undermine the pawn
no he can't take it with his rook if he
takes it with his rook one
two one so we can take his knight with
either piece
and we win we won the night okay so
moving on
c4 b5 he defends the pawn we take it
so if we were to ever attack this spawn
and we did in the end
if we were to ever attack the spawn it
would no longer be able to be protected
by another pawn
it's called isolated an isolated pawn is
a pawn that has no pawns on neighboring
files
that may be able to protect it okay
so now we go queen h4 we make our queen
stronger our queen is now
near white's king that's all there is to
it and now we look at this rook on f8
and we say
this rook is not doing anything let's
get this rook to do something now what
is this called
um what is this called what are we doing
to to white's queen
this is called a pin and i know that for
a lot of you this is very basic please
bear with me i'm trying to make this
interesting for everybody
and those of you who are more advanced
you know you will have your moment in
the sun
uh it's just that i know we have a lot
of people a lot of people new to chess
so i want to make this
at least somewhat followable this is
called a pin what is the pin
a pin is a situation just like this when
you see the knight on d5 is pinned it
cannot move because we take the queen
so one piece stares at another piece
through the lens
of another piece that's all there is to
it
that was a very clear explanation our
rook on t8 a pin involves one of your
pieces and two of your opponent's pieces
so when a piece of lesser value such as
the rook stares at a piece of greater
value such as the queen
and it does so through the lens of a
third piece that third piece is pinned
it is pinned because if it moves the
moment that it moves it exposes the
attack on
uh on that third piece okay
i myself am not too familiar with like
absolute pin i don't know the
terminology all that well
now if this knight on d5 was a black
knight
if it was a black knight that is what i
call an x-ray
an x-ray is the same thing as a pin
except we are the ones
who have that intermediate piece and we
control its movement
that's where a discovered attack comes
in right we can move that piece
and we open up an attack on that white
queen if this night we're a black knight
we would move that black knight and we
would be threatening the queen
an absolute pin is a pit on the king yes
where that piece literally by
rule cannot move if this queen were to
be a white king if the white king were
here
then this would be an absolute pin
because the knight
literally cannot move if this is a queen
hey
the knight can move but this knight's
going to get fired from its job because
hey we don't want to lose a queen so
brad goes rook d1 he gives the knight
some support h6
and i think so far brad has been playing
really well rook to f3 lifting up the
rope this is called a rook lift
it's where you lift the rook up to one
of these squares
in order to mount an attack against the
enemy king
um in the actual position if there
wasn't a second rook
yeah exactly you would discover yeah
you're exactly right you could also move
a pin piece away with check
and end up in that way
so now we go rook to d7 and uh
why h why open the h7 square instead of
jason fantastic question
why didn't we go here how did i choose
this square over this square
it's not about this square being any
worse than this square it's just that
the move g6
is a big mistake because it weakens the
f6 where the knight could jump onto f6
guess what
we moved a pinned piece away but we did
it with check
so i can't take white's queen because
the king is in check i have to move my
king
and now the queen is free to run well
look at how good this night this night
is just
sexy as hell it's this night guy got a
matches even before i made a tinder
account
i mean this is called an outpost by the
way so the knight is
the nine is awesome um okay um
anyways g6 that's the reason so h6
and rook to f3 now we go rook to d7
can somebody remind me why i made this
move
why did i play rook d7
it gives the queen a retreat square why
do we need a retreat square well brad
showed us why rook h3 and if i didn't
have this square
the queen would not have a lot of good
spots so we can drop the king back to
the gate it is safe here
and the queen and the rook now pile up
on the d5 knight this is called doubling
pieces or stacking the rook of the queen
could you have taken the queen on f2 yes
perhaps that would have been a good move
but i was a little bit afraid
that was i was a little bit afraid of
putting the queen here i probably should
have done this though because according
to brad
knight to f6 check was super strong here
sacrificing the knight
in order to open up my king that's a
beautiful move and now i guess here
with a very very strong attack wow you
might be winning here actually
that's pretty that's pretty cool because
the king is super super vulnerable here
bishop takes h6 queen g8 and this is a
check made in just a couple of moves
amazing so brad actually had a very very
uh
strong tactical move here knight f6
check
and it's not that clear because i can
take the knight with a queen
and then i can take white's queen but uh
white is now up in exchange so white is
definitely better here
so can you show us the checkmate okay so
let me spell this out for everybody
the move that brad had is knight to f6
check this is again removing the knight
from the pin but you can't take white's
uh white screen because this is czech
but you guys might look at this and say
well wait a second first of all if you
do not
take the knight not all sacrifices have
to be accepted
let's say you move the king what's the
problem with this move
well who can tell me simple what's the
problem with this move
yeah we just give up the rook we don't
want to give up the rook that's a free
rook
so we have two ways of taking the knight
if we take the knight with the queen
which
is the correct move but the problem with
this move is
the pawn takes the queen now we take
white's queen
and white takes our rook so at the end
of the day when you tally up the balance
when the checkbooks are balanced
white has a rook for a bishop so white
has an extra exchange
a rook is generally worth five points a
bishop is worth three points so
white is up let's say two points which
is quite a lot
so therefore it seems necessary to take
the night with a pawn
but um when there is any capture a
little piece of advice for beginners but
basically for everybody
when there is a capture of any sort you
have to take a couple of seconds
and understand how the position has
qualitatively changed as a result of the
capture
what is now the case which didn't used
to be the case what observations can you
make
about how the position has transformed
and what can we say here well
first of all the pawns are no longer
perfect but the way that that manifests
itself
is that this g file used to be closed
by black's pawn is now open the pawn is
shifted away
and that is exactly what white exploits
by playing queen to g3 check
now black's king can run in two
different directions if you if it runs
to h7 this cov this pawn is very flimsy
cover
it can be taken by the rook the bishop
defends the rook this is checkmate
the king must run the other way but it
doesn't get very far white takes the
pawn with the bishop
the king runs to e8 now the queen gives
the check
to the king forcing the king up to e7
now white takes the pawn with check the
king can't run to d6 the rook is
covering that square
so the king has to take the pawn on f6
and now white has checkmate in a variety
of different ways who can tell me one
way
to deliver checkmate let's see if i can
find the mate one
two oh one second i'm thinking
i'm sure there is probably checkmate in
just a couple moves yeah check
now you can give another check the pawn
can't cover the check because the pawn
is pinned
king has to drop back and now rook h8
check every
single piece is involved in the attack
the bishop has to cover
and this is now checkmate that is just
one of several mates in that position
but it's probably the best it's a
beautiful attack
absolutely filthy attack on the king
that is what an attack is when you hear
the word attack thrown out
an attack on the king is when you try to
checkmate the king with a sustained
effort uh and attacks don't always
succeed sometimes they fail
that's where defense comes in but brad
played queen g3 first
and this gave me time to take the knight
on d5
i finally remove the knight from the
board i remove his strongest piece from
the board
now brad makes the move bishop takes h6
this is called an intermediate move or
an internet zone some chess terms are
either german or italian because of the
contributions that they've made to chess
we sort of honor that by referring to
some moves informally by their
foreign language name and what you know
you can say in between move
but we often say it's vision zog which
is the german word or uh
inter mezzo which is the italian word
both mean in between both
so he plays the in-between move bishop
takes h6 he could have captured our
bishop but then we would have taken his
pawn
and at the end of the day we are up a
pawn and we're threatening the
background checkmate on d1 but brad
takes on h6 posing the threat of queen
takes g7 checkmate
now the last important moment in the
game okay and
this is complicated i'm just gonna warn
you guys straight away this is very
concrete and it's very complicated but
i'll try my best to explain it clearly
i'll do my best so
first of all let's understand what's
going on here from a high level
perspective let's make some observations
that are going to help us
follow these complications first of all
what is white threatening here there are
two specific things
that white is threatening in order of
priority
priority number one sort of threat
number one is of course checkmate on g7
let's make a random move
white is threatening to deliver
checkmate so
any black move has to either defend
against the checkmate
in some way or deliver a check every
other move would get checkmated
what is white's other threat i know that
checkmate is the biggest threat well
what is white's other threat
no simple don't overthink it don't
overthink it to take the bishop right
white also threatens to recapture the
bishop remember white did not capture
the bishop with his last move he
captured a pawn so remember
i want to ask you guys about a situation
do you guys remember let rewind rewind
or rewind
all the way back to the opening when
brad took our knight on d7
some people were proposing an
intermediate move i compared this to
uh what did i i made a weird comparison
i guess to um
to knock out knockout basketball you
wanna you're you're losing the piece
you already missed the shot you're going
to lose the piece so you might as well
give a piece
up for as much as possible people wanted
knight takes e2 which is a healthy move
but it didn't work for a complicated
reason well let's transfer that ability
over to
this position that we're looking at now
a lot of people were saying well i'm
going to lose the bishop
anyway so why don't we take on g2 with
check
and ruin the protection on white's king
so from a conceptual standpoint this is
a great move
but the problem is concrete now if white
takes the bishop with the queen that
would be a very bad move
because we take the rook with check
again with check
that's why white can't deliver checkmate
because it's czech and white loses the
game because the king has no escape
squares white has to give up the queen
but what happens is that black white
takes on g2 with the king
and because he takes with the king
believe it or not i know it sounds weird
but the king is safer here
than here why is that why is the king
safer on g2 and this is the complicated
reason
the king is safer on g2 than on h1
because
optically that the opposite seems to be
there is no back rank
uh checkmate the king on g2 has access
to a lot of escape squares
whereas the king on h1 is boxed in so
any check
on this first rank would be checkmate
and specifically
white can do the same thing that he did
in the game let's say that i play
bishop to f8 brad plays the move bishop
to g5
and this time i have no uh move that i
had in the game
because the king is is free to roam and
white's going to play queen h4 and check
maybe
so now we see what i played i played the
media bishop f8 protecting the g7 square
brad goes bishop g5 and had he taken my
bishop now i would have taken on d5 and
once again
i create the threat of checkmate on d1
the same thing would not have been
possible
with the move bishop to hg2 check but
brad goes bishop g5 he attacks my queen
another intermediate move
now if we just uh sort of in docile
fashion move the queen away then white
goes queen h4
queen and the rook are stacked up or
doubled and because they are doubled
white threatens a devastating checkmate
on h8
or on h7 and i didn't see a good defense
to this
but instead i move my bishop away
that is the ultimate reason i didn't
take on g2 i preserve my bishop
and if he takes my queen then this is
checkmate after queenie one of them
takes you one
yep your pieces block the pawns from
making
uh luft as we say luft is the german
word i think for air
for the king and so
the game is basically over rookie one
now comes another complicated moment
because once again if we move our queen
away then white ghost win h4 just
because we're up a piece nobody's doing
any favor for that you can be up a piece
all you want but this is still a
checkmate threat
and there is no easy defense against it
if we play f6 here
to create some luft for the king white
has a gorgeous move in response to it
white to play in this position guys e6
white pushes the pawn forward to deprive
the king of the f7 square
and this pawn cannot be gotten rid of
the queen 8 trade is basically
inevitable unless black wants to give up
a queen
okay so that's why
i asked myself well is there a way to
get rid of this rook if i can get rid of
this rook
then white can put a queen on h4 all he
wants this is not going to be a
checkmate threat
so that's why i play the move rook to d3
attacking the queen
counter attacking it if white takes my
queen i take his
and at the end of the day i take the
bishop i have two amazing bishops
for a rook which is a huge advantage i'm
going to activate the bishop on f5
sorry on f8 i'm going to play bishop c5
and maybe bishop to f2 this is just
winning the rook's going to come to d2
this is uh just an amazing position
jungle jungle asks what happens after
okay so coming back to bishop takes g2
pardon
but i want to take all the questions if
bishop takes g2
you mean in this position king takes g2
rook d2
well the problem jungle don't forget i'm
sorry don't forget about that bishop
right
you're forgetting about this bishop
which is totally understandable the
bishop is multitasking it's wearing two
different hats it's
attacking g7 but it's also defending
that square does that make sense
so when you're looking at a piece try to
understand everything it's doing
all of the squares it's controlling not
just the primary
its primary intention and so brad has to
move the queen but now the attack is
finally evaporated because if he moves
the queen to h4
then i take the rook attacking his queen
and getting rid of the attack so
the game is over queen to a5 attacks the
rook
rook rook hg3 rook takes c4 if he takes
the rook then queen takes e1 with
checkmate
queen has to move i trade rooks bring
the bishop out of the out of the gates
it's done its duty on f8 it's defended
the g7 square now it's time to
reactivate it
and this is where we already saw this
moment if queen g3
we've come full circle then i take on g2
this
is the decoy sacrifice that's what we
started with this is the decoy
distracting the queen from its
protection of the rook and if king takes
you two
you guys already are pros at detecting
pins
so this move should make perhaps a whole
deal more sense than it did when i first
showed it if i've done
a halfway decent job and so brad played
queen d2
rook c2 sacking the queen of course
quote unquote stacking it's a very
simple sacrifice
queen takes a5 bishop takes you to
checkmate
that was a very rich game thank you so
much brad it was possible thanks to your
amazing play i know that some of the
complications here were
were not easy to follow so i appreciate
everybody being patient
um thank you wow 500 bits from bayleaf
9. appreciate it
that was a really cool game uh that was
a really cool game lots of stuff
happened and
it was very close like you know it
wasn't that i crushed
that easily um and and that's ultimately
what you guys should keep in mind is
that
gm's are good but i i'm not a god of
chess and i i still need to do
i still make mistakes and i can still be
beat
thank you induced giant for the 100 bits
[Music]
you